here's a quick tip from someone we love  hey drew here's a design tip if you're  stuck on how you want your place to look  think instead about how you want it to  feel do you want your home office to be  a place that feels inspiring or your  bedroom to be a place that feels sexy  maybe you want your living room to feel  super relaxed so close your eyes  and transport yourself to the last time  you felt that way  the last time i felt truly relaxed i was  at the beach so i'm gonna pull in those  beautiful blues those sandy hues i'm  gonna bring in drift woods and washed  linen and i'm gonna take cues from that  place where i felt relaxed to design a  relaxed space in my home so let the  feeling guide you  that's  genius why didn't i think of that  [Music]  you